this is one of the coolest things I've  ever seen for two non-negative numbers  their arithmetic mean or simple average  is always greater than or equal to their  geometric mean or square root of their  product equality holds exactly when the  two numbers are equal there's an amazing  way to see this visually construct a  circle with diameter X Plus y the radius  of the circle is half the diameter so it  is the arithmetic mean now construct a  perpendicular chord where X meets y if  each semicard has length G then by the  chord chord power theorem G times G is  equal to x times Y which means G is  equal to the square root of x times y or  the geometric mean we can now  geometrically see the semi chord is  always less than or equal to the radius  with the quality if and only if x equals  y and that is precisely why the GM is  always less than or equal to the am and  thus we have proven the amgm inequality